most people have heard of the electoral
college during presidential election
years but what exactly is the Electoral
College simply say it is a group of
people appointed by each state who
formally elect the President and
vice-president of the United States to
understand how this process began and
how it continues today we can look at
the Constitution of the United States
article 2 section 1 Clause 2 of the
Constitution it specifies how many
electors each state is entitled to have
since 1964 there have been 538 electors
in each presidential election how did
they decide on the number 538 well the
number of electors is equal to the total
voting membership of the United States
Congress 435 representatives plus 100
senators and three electors from the
District of Columbia essentially the
Democratic candidate and Republican
candidate are each trying to add up the
electors in every state so that they
surpassed 270 electoral votes or just
over half of 538 votes and win the
presidency so how do states even get
electoral votes each state receives a
particular number of electors based on
population size the census is conducted
every 10 years so every time the census
happens states might gain or lose a few
electoral votes let's say you're a voter
in California a state with 55 electoral
votes if your candidate wins in
California they get all 55 of the
state's electoral votes if your
candidate loses they get no this is why
many presidential candidates want to win
states like Texas Florida and New Yorker
if you currently add up the electoral
votes of those three states you would
have 96 electoral votes even if a
candidate won North Dakota South Dakota
Montana Wyoming
mom New Hampshire Connecticut and West
Virginia they would only gain 31
electoral votes total from those eight
states here's where it can get a little
tricky on a rare occasion like in the
year 2000 someone can win the popular
vote but fail to gain 270 electoral
votes this means that the winner may
have won and collected their electoral
votes by small margins winning just
enough states with just enough electoral
votes but the losing candidate may have
captured large voter margins in the
remaining states if this is the case the
very large margin secured by the losing
candidate in the other states would add
up to over 50% of the ballots cast
nationally therefore the losing
candidate may have gained more than 50%
of the ballots cast by voters but failed
to gain 270 of the electoral votes some
critics of the electoral college argued
the system gives an unfair advantage to
states with large numbers of electoral
votes think of it this way it is
possible for candidate to not get a
single person's vote not one vote in 39
states or the District of Columbia yet
be elected president by winning the
popular vote in just 11 of these 12
states California New York Texas Florida
Pennsylvania Illinois Ohio Michigan New
Jersey North Carolina Georgia or
Virginia this is why both parties pay
attention to these states however others
argue that the Electoral College
protects small states such as Rhode
Island Vermont and New Hampshire and
even geographically large states with
small populations like Alaska Wyoming
and the Dakotas that's because a
candidate can't completely ignore small
states because in a close election every
electoral vote counts there are certain
states that have a long history of
voting for a particular party these are
known as safe states for the past four
election cycles in 1996 2000 2004 and
2008 Democrats could count on states
like Oregon Maryland Michigan and
Massachusetts whereas the Republicans
could count on states like
mississippi-alabama Kansas and Idaho
states that are teetering between
parties are called swing states in the
past for election cycles Ohio and
Florida have been swing states twice
providing electoral votes for a
Democratic candidate and twice providing
electoral votes for Republican candidate
think about it do you live in a safe
state if so is it a democratic or
republican safe state or do you live in
a swing state are your neighboring
states swing or sync is the population
in your state increasing or decreasing
and do not forget when you are watching
the electro returns on election night
every four years and the big map of the
United States is on the screen know that
the magic number is 270 and start adding
you